NATHAN STRUE: Hey, everyone.
Really excited to be
here today and give you
a talk about design, which
is just an amazing thing
to talk about.
My name's Nathan Streu.
I lead Product UX for
the Google Play product.
And joining me on stage is
Taddeo Zacchini and Will
Kiefer, both colleagues of
mine who both work on Play.
So here we are.
Lovely photos.
So pretty much
everyone in the room
should be familiar with
the Google Play product.
And if you're not, we
are not just a store.
We are responsible for all of
the other media applications
that make up the Play family.
And we're not just on
the Android platform.
We also work on iOS
and on the web as well.
And so at this stage
in your I/O experience,
you should be
very, very familiar
with material design
at this point,
or at least somewhat
familiar from the keynote
and other sessions.
So we're here today to talk
about how, as an apps team,
we have been approaching the
material design within Play.
And hopefully get
you guys on a path
to purposeful and considered
design improvements.
And we're not here today to
reveal the new Play products
or features or to
announce a ship date.
But what we want to
do is to give you
a peek behind the curtain
about how our team is thinking
about the same challenges
and opportunities
you encounter as you are
addressing a robust platform
update, such as L. And so
all of the mocks in motion
studies we're going to show
you today are just iterative.
They don't represent
the final products,
and we're continuing to work
hard over the coming months
to bring this vision
to life for you.
And so you're familiar
with the driving principles
of the new design language, such
as material is the metaphor.
We're relying on hold graphical
and intentional graphics
in that our motion
is providing meaning.
And when we started working
with material design,
we were incredibly excited
about the opportunity
that was ahead of us.
And so today, I want
to run through some
of these things we were
super excited about.
So again, material
designs motion story
is meaningful and appropriate.
It's serving to focus attention
and maintain continuity
throughout your user experience.
The feedback is
subtle and clear,
and transitions are meaningful.
Interior design also relies on
the fundamental print design
tools that you may have heard
of earlier, such as baseline
grids, instructional
template that
can scale across
various page types.
The improved structural guidance
is super important for the Play
product Because since
we're a suite of products,
it's incredibly important for us
to maintain visual consistency
among them.
Some of the other things
we're looking at and super
excited about was the bold
and colorful language.
It cannot only help tell
your brand story but can also
provide more engagement and
enrichment within your UIs.
And as the designers in
the room should know,
too many types sizes and styles
can totally wreck a layout.
It can confuse the
visual hierarchy
and dramatically affect
the user experience.
So material designs
typography set
offers a variety of type
sizes that can work seamlessly
with the layout grids
that we described before.
In a material design
imagery, whether it's
illustration or photography, not
only provides visual interest
to the page, but it can
provide the user with context.
In Play we think of images
as the heroes of our UI,
as it puts the emphasis on
the content you guys love.
Like your favorite music
albums, your favorite movies,
your favorite books,
and combine together
the material guidelines
make it easier than ever
to scale your products
to multiple platforms.
And part of what
really excited us
was that we felt
like we were already
doing a lot of
these things right.
And my point is that a lot
of you guys in the room
are also doing
these things right.
We see apps every single
day on the Android ecosystem
that are just getting
better and better
and follow a lot of
these same principles.
The thing was that material
design has given us
a much bigger
sandbox to play in.
And it's making it
a lot easier for us
to do the types of experiences
that we want to do.
And so I'm going to take
a step back a little bit.
And so I joined the plate
in about two years ago.
And at that point, the product
was in a much different place
as you can see by these images.
We were doing a lot of things
well, but we have a lot of work
to do.
And so as we work together with
our product and engineering
partners, we really wanted to
set out very specific product
goals and redefine how we're
positioning Play, things
like telling a cohesive
brand story among all
the different content types.
We want to create a
consistent and responsive UX
framework that can scale.
We wanted to build shared
engineering components,
and we wanted to make
sure we were working
with a top down product vision
that everyone could align to.
Maybe most importantly,
the design team really
wanted to focus on
building relationships
with partners outside of design.
Our engineering partners,
our product partners,
our marketing partners
with very early involvement
in an iterative design approach.
And so we set out to define
a visual and interaction
framework that can scale
responsibly to multiple device
types and orientations.
We want it to be very
expressive with our color
to give each product
in the family
its own personality while
not overwhelming the content.
And also because Play
is a media product,
we wanted to make sure that our
content is front and center.
We wanted to represent
it as best as we could.
And so as we were thinking
about our current design
in the material
world, the challenge
seemed daunting at first.
You know, you have a
new platform update,
things can be a little scary.
What am I going to do?
Do we redesign
from the ground up?
And I'm sure a lot of you guys
are probably in the same boat.
And so, you've recently
updated your products.
How should you go about
addressing this issue.
And we cose to see it rather as
a challenge, as an opportunity.
So we wanted to take a step
back and address and identify
some of these core
opportunities in our UI.
And so we started with
our current product.
We wanted to identify
our hero screens,
and review them
together as a team.
And so our hero screens
were the key screens
that represented a subset of
the pages within the entire UI.
Things like our
product detail pages,
our library views,
our landing pages.
And we wanted to identify the
common UI elements and patterns
that existed across these
pages, and take note of them
and look at where we
could make improvements.
And because design
doesn't happen
in a vacuum and
great product doesn't
get created without advocacy
of folks outside of design,
things like quality
and craftsmanship,
and attention to detail.
It's very important for
groups outside of design
to understand these things
and to embrace them.
And so we really wanted
to workshop together
with these partners.
Inviting them in, doing a
series of different workshops,
getting their feedback and
involvement as early and often
as possible so that we
could all be thinking ahead
and understand the vision
that we're sharing together.
And so workshopping helps get
everybody on the same page
and gets a lot of
high-level thinking there.
But our next step
was to really get
a little more tactical about it.
Meaning like our team
likes to use Sprint
methods, where we take very
specific design challenges
and go heads down
across disciplines,
working on very similar
design problems.
Again sharing that work often.
And this can be a
day-long exercise,
this can be a
week-long exercise.
It just depends on the
complexity of the problem.
And so quickly recap here.
I just want underscore the
fact that it's really important
to approach material
design and thinking
about the opportunities
within your product.
It's not just about
design, but it's
about how you work
together with your teams.
To bring that institutional
advocacy and importance
to these sometimes subtle
things., the craftsmanship.
Thoughtful design is just not
about being a differentiator
anymore.
It's pretty much table
stakes at this point.
So earlier today in
this room, a good friend
of mine, Marco,
and Karill talked
about how we approached
the responsive design
problem in Play.
And we spent a lot of
time in our current UI
thinking about our structure.
And so with material
design, we didn't
want to throw away that
really good thinking
that we had invested
lots of time in.
We wanted to leverage
our existing structure
but be a little more deliberate,
so we could take advantages
of the opportunities that
we had and connecting
the structure and
more logical ways.
So again, the reason why
I'm underscoring this point
is that many of you
may have a product,
you may have a general
structure, an architecture
that you feel pretty happy with.
And you like us, we
didn't feel like we
needed to reinvent the
wheel on everything.
We wanted to be very tactical.
For instance, one of the
structural opportunities
we wanted to look at
was our card system.
If you're familiar
with the Play product,
we obviously
leverage like Google
does the card metaphor
to represent content.
5 So the material framework
was giving us an opportunity
to do really great things
like the dynamic shadowing,
and the transformation
from scene to scene.
And so we really
wanted to use this
as an example of one
structural component
that we saw as a very
opportunistic way
to bring a lot of
value to the product.
So keep in mind, just like
design is in a vacuum,
we weren't thinking of
structure in isolation.
We try to avoid the waterfall
process where you identify
things, it goes
to visual design,
then to interaction
design, maybe motion,
at some point it ends up
in the hands of engineers.
But the point is we want to
advocate a parallel process
where this is obviously
dependent on the size
of your team.
But we wanted to
advocate a process where
we're working together
and in parallel
to iterate on these ideas.
Because we draw a lot of
inspiration from one another.
Visual layout can greatly
affect interaction design
and visual design
can do storyboarding
to influence motion design.
And we can all riff
off of one another.
I'm going to bring to Taddeo
to the stage where we're
going to talk a
little bit about how
this work we did
in the beginning
will set up some
of the design work.
Taddeo will show you.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: Thank you Nate.
Hello everyone.
So now that we have a
solid structuring place,
let's see how we work
and how we bring together
and visualizing Google
Play Material Design.
So first we went crazy.
And structure and guidelines
a really important.
But to evolve with language,
we wanted to have inspiration.
We require inspiration.
So we went pretty crazy in
creating tons of visual design
without too much consideration
on the material design
guidelines at these points.
So we're exploring
from iconography
to typopraphy, images
and motion as well.
There was some good stuff,
maybe too out of scope.
But as you can
imagine, we have a lot
of reviews and with
the goal of narrowing
all these tremendous
amount of creative work
with material design.
And at the same time,
we set another goal
that was to create a visual
system that can give our Play
product a unique
voice and respecting
the individual needs
of the Play family.
So how did we align
the visual inspiration
with material design
and then sync,
trying to keep the identity and
the personality of Google Play.
The team look at the
material design guidelines
and trying to understand
what was already
successful in our
product and also
the nature of the product which
is a very content [INAUDIBLE]
to media followup
of this product.
So we determined which aspect
of the visual design language
were more important.
And we start with
typography which
can have a huge
impact in your app,
such as interaction or
hierarchy or eligibility
and also branding.
So with material design,
one of the benefit
is that we have a pretty
large inflexible fund family.
And we want to expand our
topography uses in the product
and make it more purposeful
and more compelling.
So we apply more style,
style for the theme,
for the medium, for
action and so on,
and make it more appropriate.
And we want to give the
page more breathing room,
feel less clutter
and complicated.
And so we had a generous
amount of padding
and we play with
alignment as well.
So these will give the UI a
more fresh and modern and clean,
and the text will be
more easier to read.
So we also increased
the contrast
in adjusting the scale
of the typography
to make the hierarchy more
cleaner and easy to read.
And we explore also
overlaying typography
in content which can
be really powerful.
And considering things
like legibility of the text
without compromising the
image and the masses.
And then colors.
Colors can be really
powerful in your design.
And with material design,
we embrace it completely.
So we take advantage of these
beautiful new material design
color palette, which
represent the brand colors.
And we wanted to
apply it to our URI,
so we believe that
we wanted to make
the colors more
vivid and exciting.
And so we started redefining
all the usage of our color
in the whole Play experience.
And we made the color
brighter and more vibrant
to represent more the
Google Play brand.
And also add a more
fresh and modern look.
And there's also the functional
aspect of using color.
You have a sense of place.
You know where you are.
Or actions are more highlighted
and more easy to read.
We also play with
color extraction
which is a really important part
of material design guidelines.
And you can see
how it works well
in a service like Play
which is a media service.
So This is a great example to
show you how much your design
guidelines can be
flexible enough
to make your own color pallet.
In fact, we extract
the color that we need
and we make our
own color pallet.
Imagery.
When you think about Play, you
think about content, media.
It's defined by its own content.
Which, of course, rely
heavily on images.
So we always want it to be bold.
And we were already pretty bold
right now with the products.
But we want to be
even more immersive
and represent the content
in all its beauty.
And most importantly, we want to
create an emotional connection
between the user
and the content.
So we start developing
for different screen size,
and you can't imagine
how big and bold can
be the images in a larger
screen such as TV or a tablet.
So the contents
speak for itself.
And the contents are
real here on the page.
Of course we align other
things to material design,
like the grid, the
layout, the metric,
and, of course,
iconography as well.
So you can see that everything
has a consistent visual story.
And the Play experience feel
like part of the same family.
And this could be a
possible evolution
of however we use a language.
You have material
design applied.
So these were the three
areas as of our user language
that we did our first pass.
And for other problems such as
text editor app or a messaging
app, your starting point
can be totally different.
But there's something
more important
that is missing
here that combined
all these things together
and with interaction
and actually make a truly
enchanting and magic
experience, which is motion.
One of the core aspects
of material design,
as you are already
probably know,
is how can motion design
bring life into a product.
We were really
excited about that.
So the team and visual
designer were already
exploring all this stuff before
in an our early exploration.
So we were doing also
visual expiration
and storyboard that
can represent motion
and can be easily translated
into moving images.
So we started thinking
about how we can find a way
to tie all these things
together and thinking
about how the user moves
through the experience
and how to interact and
engage in the content.
And the emotion that you
feel doing all of these.
So we can apply motion
without a story.
And what is our motion story?
It's been straightforward.
It is a typical story.
There is a starting
point where in the motion
world can be translated like
the user is guide to the UI
and how things appear
and how things load.
And then there is a medial
stage where the action happened
and what's the feeling and
emotion that the user is
feeling at the moment.
And then there is the end
where the animation is actually
resolving.
So where user lands into the
page after the animation.
So as Nate mentioned before,
we define hero screen,
but also we define
hero moments that
were guide all these
explorations that you're
going to see today,
and things like
how the object move in the
space, how the object appears
or transitions, and
most importantly, create
meaningful motion that
can connect emotionally
and can make you feel something.
So taking on the latest
structures [INAUDIBLE]
was talking about
before, you can already
see that one sees emotion.
You understand where the objects
are and how they could move
and potentially how you
can interact with them.
And the parallax effect,
not just the flavor
or just the fashion things that
everyone is using right now.
But it's actually
purposeful for the motion.
You understand where
the objects are
and how you can
interact with them.
Blocking out animation.
Once we were starting doing
this prototype and exploration,
it was really important to
get the animation right.
So we reduce completely, the
level of detail and thinking
blocks, and focus only on the
motion and the actual sense
of the motion and
bring the movement
as natural as possible.
So don't worry about around the
corner, or pixel perfect stuff
in this time.
So this is our early
exploration where
we wanted to show how
things load in the page.
But we weren't quite
happy with that
because there is
too much going on.
There is too much tilting
the card too fast.
And it was an
overwhelming experience.
User will actually too
distracted from the movement.
So we simplify the transition
and make it more simple,
and guide the user
attention and focus
through the actual important
thing, which is the content.
So we explore also
how content loads
when there is a measured
change in the screen layout.
Like in this case, you
talk to a collection,
and you go into
the detail phase.
And what is very interesting
here is with material design,
you have a feeling that you
have full control of the UI,
and that you
actually almost paint
the screen with you finger.
And here's another
example of how
things can load from a place
into a totally different place.
Like here, I'm in
a home home phase,
and then I'm going
to a detail page.
And here, example of how we
could interact with objects
like opening and closing.
In this case, in Newsstand,
you're opening the object
and the card expands.
And it goes S to S until
it gets full screen,
and you see the real
content in all its beauty.
So this transition is
especially important
because you have a special sense
of where things are removed.
And in this case, the
most important thing
is the backward transition, with
if we had to tell the story,
you have to tell
a complete story.
So you want also to
[INAUDIBLE] and key experience
once you're going back.
So backward
transition for us was
crucial as any other key motion.
Of course, we were doing
all of this motion study
with engineering and each
array team and reviewing.
But Will will go in
depth about that.
Again, opening and closing
elements is fast using place.
The card expand and contract.
The object is marked.
He knows where he comes from,
and he knows where he lands.
And of course, detailed matter.
So we look at
purposeful animation
and enhance the overall
experience with little touches.
Like in this case,
the loading spinner.
You also have a chance
to brand these things,
so we were trying to
express the product that we
were showing-- in
this case, movies.
So this will give the user
an engagement, and also
a little bit of surprise
and curiosity to the UI.
Again, details are
important, so an animation
that could be static
and pretty boring,
we actually trying to make a
storytelling aspect into it.
So like the downloading arrow.
So here, this is
an example of how
can be the potential
complete story once you
combine all these
pieces together.
So these are our here moments.
Every half has their own one.
So it is up to you
to define which one.
So this is just
part of the magic.
This is mean nothing
without the actual someone
that can make it real.
And as Nathan was
mentioning before,
it was that effort of
the team working together
with the engineering
product researcher.
And this time, we'll have
Will talking about in detail
how we actually
did these things.
Thank you.
WILL KIEFER: Thank you Teddy.
So I'm going to give you
guys a little glimpse
into the engineering
process, and what
was going on throughout
all this on the engineering
side of things.
And the key takeaway is
really that it was the same.
We were working in
parallel and collaborating
sort of simultaneously
back and forth.
And one of the early
things Nate mentioned
is the early stage of
identifying your opportunities,
right?
I'm really lucky,
because I actually
work on both UX frameworks
and on the Play suite apps.
And so I kind of get
to wear both hats,
and there are opportunities
in both of these places.
So the core tenant
from the framework side
of things, the core
opportunity there
was to make it really
easy for your apps.
We basically wanted to bake the
material DNA into the framework
so that that stuff just
comes along with your apps,
and life is easy,
and you can focus
on making the subtlety that
is appropriate for your app.
So things like cards are
first class citizens now.
So you have consistency
across your cards in your app,
across the system, the
notification, the system UI,
and it feels like
part of one family.
And there's elevation and
layering for your hero images,
or your hero content.
And then shadows, for maybe you
have custom shadows for content
that doesn't quite fit in
what the framework provides.
That's all there.
Complex layouts are
now much easier.
Everyone knows that,
design and engineering
knows that list
view is very arduous
to do some complex things.
So now you have
actual proper support
both in L and in the compat
library with recycler view
to make layouts that are
appropriate for your content.
And actual support for animating
things in and animating things
out.
So it's really nice.
And actually, my
personal favorite
is the suite of API's
around scene transitions.
This opens up a whole new
category of story and design
for your app that just basically
wasn't possible before.
And scene transitions are how
you're app or your activity
animates in and then animates
out when it's disappearing.
And this is into your app, or
across activities in your app,
or even between applications.
It's really pretty powerful.
If you want to dig into some
of the things, some of this
a little deeper, yesterday's
"What's New in Android" talk
is on video, is a great
whirlwind tour of everything.
And then actually
right now, there's
a talk on material
science where they dig in.
You can catch it on video.
And I think at 2:00 PM,
there's another talk
where they're going to
walk through actually
building material witness.
Building an actual android
app with all this stuff.
So that's a little bit of the
opportunities on the framework
side.
And so apps have their own
sort of personal opportunities.
Nate mentioned what Play
was looking at early on.
Your apps may have
different things,
but the other opportunities
to leverage the framework.
So next up was structure.
And this is actually
really interesting
because one of my other favorite
parts about the material design
language is it has
very strong guidelines.
It's very opinionated, and
has a strong philosophy.
But it's not actually very
rigid in your app structure.
There's actually a lot of
flexibility in the system
to make an app that
fits your content,
fits your structure,
fits what you want to do.
And so earlier, Teddy
alluded to the structure
that Play was developing.
And this didn't just
sort of come overnight,
and get thrown over the wall
from design to engineering.
This is a really good example
where we're working together
in parallel and
collaborating here.
So I'm going to
share little vignette
of an actual true story
of Play Newsstand,
and how that was happening.
So early on, I saw some amazing
blue sky sort of moments.
Visual mocks in motion
design and stuff.
So I just went and
started prototyping.
And so everything you see here
is actual random prototypes
from this time off my laptop.
And I worked at it.
I did a whole bunch
of iterations.
I may builds.
And I just was not happy.
There were a couple
issues that came up
when actually implementing
it that were really,
I felt like we were going
to have to start over, take
a new direction.
There was issues with tabs and
having layers actually split
when we scroll, and trying to
blend these different layers
and parallax.
And it's they're subtle
issues, but they were there.
And so basically, I was
giving daily builds.
And one day I thought, oh man.
OK, we're going to
have to start over.
So I turned it off.
I reverted it, and
the next day, they
would build, like went back to
a sort of a previous iteration.
And a designer, the legendary
Marco, came up to me that day
and was like, hey.
Where did that go?
This was awesome, I loved it.
And I said, oh.
Well, obviously, it can't work
because of engineering reason
A, B, C. And he
said, no, no, no.
We can do this.
Let's iterate, let's
solve those problems.
And so we ended up
coming to a place--
this is sort of the next stage
where we're like, oh yeah.
It's actually working.
This is, I think we can
pursue this structure.
And this would not have
happened had we not
actually been prototyping
and iterating together.
Having people live
with prototypes,
even if they're very
rough and not quite right,
really lets you know if
the structure's going
to work because
you're living with it.
You can see what works,
what doesn't work.
And so this is like
the next stage.
We're getting a little bit
closer, and feeling like yes.
We could pursue this structure.
And once we got there,
then the whole sort
of rest of the pieces of the
app started to fall into place,
and become a cohesive
story around this.
So that's a little
glimpse of the structure.
Iterating in conjunction with
each other, living with it,
and solving the structure
early on with prototypes
to basically prove out the
technical feasibility of
is that going to work?
And you'll notice I showed
some iOS footage there.
And Play is a cross
platform product.
So this was going up, we were
firing on all cylinders, web,
iOS, and Android, because the
challenges on each platform
are going to be a
little bit different
and the interaction models
can be a little bit different.
And so it's really
important that if you're
doing cross product
work, that you're
kind of repeating this
process in parallel
across the different platforms.
So the final piece
is story, and Teddy
talked about this a little bit.
And so what is story?
It's basically connecting
these hero moments
that you've defined for your
app using motion design,
and using animation.
And this animation is
not actually fluff.
It's not eye candy.
It's very purposeful.
So when a user touches on a
card with an image and a title,
and that image and
title stays on screen,
transitions into place, and
supporting content and details
appear to basically
supplement it.
There are fewer pixels
moving on the screen.
And with your pixels
moving, there's
actually less cognitive
overhead for your user.
If it's an abrupt transition,
and everything changes at once
there's a lot more
cognitive overhead.
The user has to sort
of rescan everything,
and reacquaint themselves
with where everything went.
So this is very,
very purposeful.
And that doesn't
mean everything has
to be completely
smooth everywhere.
There can be abrupt changes
just like in novels, and film,
and music.
There can be abrupt changes,
but they're purposeful.
They're there for a reason.
And so we looked at
Newsstand and we said, OK.
What's one of our really
common transitions that now we
can leverage this opportunity?
And so collections of cards of
articles to the actual article
themselves.
And you saw some of the motion
studies on this earlier.
This was a great
opportunity for us.
And how did engineering actually
tackle this at the same time
that the motion designers
were working on it?
We used the same techniques.
We use Block-it.
Here's a random, early
prototype of just getting
the blocks in place, and
giving the designers knobs
to tweak like live on
the device to adjust
timings and curves,
and all sorts of stuff
so that they get really
immediate feedback
to feel what's working.
Because when it's in your hand,
it just changes everything.
Here's another example
in tablet where
I slowed the entire
animation down.
I used a big, bright,
red debug color
just so I could really
focus on what was going on.
And here, it turned out
that this was not right.
You'll see the right edge, it's
the right edge of the tablet
before the left side does.
And it wasn't quite right.
It wasn't working.
So we iterated, and we adjusted.
And you wouldn't really
notice that if you just
put in the final
sort of transition
without the color and
stuff, because it might just
look pretty good in our right.
But really slowing it down and
getting those details right.
And so blocking is actually
very helpful on an engineering
prospective.
And so when you start putting
all these things together,
you get this motion story
without these rough edges.
And everything you do
and touch with the screen
is purposeful and interactive.
And it's important here
that these early prototypes,
the level of details high.
This is not perfect.
There's a lot of bugs, there's
a lot of weird color and issues.
But the important part is
that at a granular level,
it's where you're going.
And you live with it, and
you see if it's working.
So that's a little
bit about Story.
And finally, I just wanted
to basically highlight
two sort of key takeaways
from our talk today.
And one is this idea
that Nate mentioned
of institutional
advocacy for design.
If everybody is involved
in design, than everybody
feels a bit of ownership
over that design.
And if everyone feels
ownership of that design,
then everyone is
invested in it, and you
get much better results.
We have engineering product and
design all working together.
And this scales.
This scales from a one person
indie dev to a big company.
Design advocacy applies
in both situations.
And arguably, it's
even more important
when your team is much
bigger, because it's
easier to sort of start
throwing things over the wall.
And you don't get quite
as good results that way.
And the last point is
leveraging your opportunity.
This is basically finding
those hero moments,
finding of the parts
of your app you
want to improve with the
parts of your app you want
to highlight, and building
around those first.
Build blue skies, building
really nice mocks,
and working out from there using
those to define your structure,
or refine your
structure if you already
feel very happy
with what you have.
And then, prototyping early.
Building that stuff, living
with it to see if it's working.
And then connecting those
dots using the motion study
in the story that
you want for the app.
And this is just
really fantastic,
because material design
gives you these tools
to basically connect all
this together and improve
how everything works.
So thank you for coming out
and by letting us give you
a little sneak peek
into what Play is doing.
And we've got a little bit of
time for questions I think,
about 10 minutes.
So I'll hand the mic to Nate,
and then you can answer.
NATHAN STRUE: Thanks everyone.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: Thank you.
WILL KIEFER: Yeah, there's
mikes on both sides of the room
if anyone has anything.
And if not, you can always
find us afterwards too.
NATHAN STRUE: No?
Crickets.
WILL KIEFER: Crickets.
AUDIENCE: You guys, is this on?
Can you guys talk a little
bit about your process
and the tools that you use?
Who on the team is
the creative lead?
Who comes up with the concept?
Before you invest a bunch
of time prototyping,
you probably should
put that into some sort
of a software that's
easier than a software
that you're writing code.
NATHAN STRUE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So what
are those tips?
NATHAN STRUE: I think it's a
little variable for everyone,
depending on the
size of the team,
depending on what tools
you're comfortable with.
We have the benefit of
working with a good sized team
where we have people with
some After Effects skills who
are doing quick prototyping,
motion studies, leveraging,
some of the visual
mocks and assets
that have already been created.
But it can be whatever
works for you, whatever
works quickly and fast
to get you to a point
where you can really start
feeling how something
is working in your hand.
I think it's variable.
For us, it's a combination
of some internal tools
that we've developed in addition
to things like After Effects.
But it's usually variable.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: But even the
process that we are actually
doing, we are starting
maybe from sketches,
and then we go into static
modes with Illustrator,
and then we pass it
through the prototyper.
And with After Effects, in five
seconds it does everything.
So it could be that, or it
could be just directly on
After Effects.
So it's variable.
Depends on the interact and
the motion that we want to do.
WILL KIEFER: And we also,
even just really simple HTML
prototypes too.
NATHAN STRUE: Yep.
WILL KIEFER: Definitely
take advantage of those just
to get something quick and
on a browser on the device.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What do you find are the
best methods and practices
for getting good design
advocacy, especially
across large platforms?
Since Play covers
so many domains,
I figured this might be
something that you could offer
some insight into and something
that my company's just
now getting really big about.
So it's got some
bumps and bruises.
Any advice would be awesome.
NATHAN STRUE: Sure.
I mean it's a tough
thing to tackle, right?
Google historically, has been
an engineering driven company.
And design over the
last two to three years
has really become--
from Larry down,
something that is
incredibly important.
So I think the sooner you can
engage folks who are driving,
the better.
And it never hurts to
give, show people examples.
Like this is the other
products in the wild.
They don't even necessarily
have to be competitive products.
Being able to show people
like the state of the art,
like what people are
doing is hugely important
because not everybody knows.
If you're not in a design world
or you're not in an engineering
world, I think it's
really important
to let people know what
is going on in the wild,
and how these innovations
are happening quickly.
And the quality bar is
raising all the time.
So it has to be considered.
WILL KIEFER: And then
on the flip side,
I'd also say that there's
a grassroots approach too.
If your leadership
is not necessarily
happy about doing that, is
that designers and engineers
can just work together.
Like literally, that moment
of just collaborating and just
brainstorming, involving
each other in that part
is really nice.
Because then you're
on board together.
That was really good in the
early days of Newsstand.
We got a couple engineers and
a couple designers in a room
with basically where do
we want to be in 10 years?
And where do we want
to be in five years?
And just work it out.
And then you feel like
you're on the same team.
So then you both have
ownership over it.
So it's easier to drive back
just from the bottom layer too.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
WILL KIEFER: Oh, here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Prishan.
I run a small app company.
One point of contention
we have is basically
when to do the handover
from engineering
to design, essentially.
So my designer come up with
big, [INAUDIBLE] feature.
My designer come up
with this beautiful UI
layout and workflow.
And then you first
thing they say
that this is not a
standard UI component.
You should think in terms
of standard UI components
available.
And also when
standardization, A,
do you encourage using
only the standard UI
component because
user are familiar
and there's less learning curve,
and when to empower design?
How do you make the decision?
NATHAN STRUE: Sure.
No, that's a very good question,
and I think super relevant.
I think there's a lot of factors
that go into that hand off.
I mean, I think it depends the
competency of your designers
and how familiar
they are with working
with framework components.
And as Will was talking about,
it's that collaboration.
So if there are designers that
aren't fully aware of what
the suite of a
framework can offer,
it's really good to try
to bring them up to speed.
And also going back to how we
were discussing opportunity,
it's like where do you get
the most value, the most
bang for your buck in
going a custom route?
Now for certain
experiences, taking
what the framework offers you
with minor changes, things that
are easy to do in code, that can
make a big difference in design
like changing font scaling,
are changing color palates,
changing background assets.
These things are
relatively cheap ways
that still leverage
the framework,
but can give you a very
different look and feel.
But it's also about when is
it appropriate to override
the framework or do
something custom?
And I think that decision
comes from working together
as a team, and determining
whether or not it's worth
the engineering investment.
Is the payoff going
to be big enough
on undoing a
component in custom?
As an example in
Play, maybe we don't
want to take the
platform scrubber bar,
because we want to bring
something more branded
or something that's
differentiated.
And for us maybe,
that's a big win.
I'm not saying that's
what we're doing,
but that could be an example
of how you address that.
WILL KIEFER: And from the
engineering perspective,
I'd say what's great
about material design is
it's sort of like a higher level
philosophy that's not like, use
this button.
Use this thing.
It's like, here are
the guidelines and here
the red lines, and these things.
And so actually, the compat
library and the framework
are in some ways, much
more flexible to achieve
what previously might
have been a lot more
of a custom component.
AUDIENCE: So between prototyping
with After Effects or something
more interactive like
Quartz or HTML, when
you see that payoff
in going interactive,
and what goes into
that decision making.
Is it just the skill
sets on the team,
or is there some sort
of thought process?
NATHAN STRUE: Great question.
We would advocate for
getting it in people's hands
as quickly as possible.
I mean, even literally if
it's sketches on paper that
are captured and broken up
into the variety of tools that
are available for doing quick,
iterative, rapid prototyping
on device.
We live in a world where
everything is interactive,
and statics can't capture how
something is going to feel.
And so we in general,
advocate for trying
to do that as quickly as
possible with any tool that
works.
And you can continue to refine
and iterate, and develop,
and polish as you're going.
And that tool set
can adapt depending
on what your needs are.
But the sooner you
can start playing
with something, the better.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: Yeah,
it's a parallel track.
I mean maybe the
motion designer will
start designing the motion,
and then the first draft
will get in the
prototype, and then
we figure out what we could do.
And then production
design will go ahead
and do all the pixel perfecting.
Meanwhile, the engineering
will fix the motion.
I mean, it's a collaboration.
WILL KIEFER: And I've been
known to put just static images
and movies, and view them in
gallery on the phone, just
because holding it in your
hand kind of changes it.
And so you can really get an
easy, fake interactive thing
by pressing play,
and just kind of--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NATHAN STRUE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I had a question
about creating cross platform
mobile apps.
Let's say you're working on
Android with new material
design, and you're
also working on iOS.
Both sort of have
similar design paradigms
whenever you sort
of look at depth.
IOS accomplishes that blur,
whereas material design does it
with subtle shadows.
So my question is
whenever you're
creating an app
for both platforms,
do you conform to
the design paradigms
of the specific platform?
Or should you try to just create
one single cohesive design
across both versions
of your app?
NATHAN STRUE: Sure, that's
a very good question.
I don't think there's
a direct answer.
There's certain
platform paradigms
that are very core
to a user experience.
There are some that for
instance, a good example is
when we were developing
music on iOS,
we really felt our
interaction of our tab model
was super successful.
And iOS's tab
platform didn't really
let us do the things
we wanted to do.
So that was something where
we took a pattern from Android
and applied it to iOS.
There's other areas, I
can't think of anything
off the top of my
head, but where
you do you want to conform
to the platform standards.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: Oh,
well like the back button
in the ActionWare, for example.
That's typical.
NATHAN STRUE: Sure.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: So you may
align your visual design
to this material
design guidelines.
But the interaction and some
of the key elements of the UI
can still be platform
based, like the back button.
NATHAN STRUE: You want to make
sure to respect your user's
comfort.
And if they've spent
all of their time
on a specific platform.
There's going to be certain
platform paradigms that
makes sense to adopt.
So there's not a good
definitive answer there.
I would say try to be as
consistent with the product
across all platforms as possible
in the major structural and
component elements, but
respect the platform paradigm.
WILL KIEFER: And there's some
platform sort of interactions
that are not necessarily
tied to the model.
Like the edge swipe
on iOS to go back.
You can support that without
changing your design.
But unfortunately,
we're out of time.
So I really thank
you guys again.
You can come grab us afterwards
if you have more questions.
NATHAN STRUE: Thanks, everyone.
TADDEO ZACCHINI: Thank you.